all right so thank you so much
it's uh pretty fantastic to be back
connected at least virtually with
stanford when i was a grad student there
i went to the pc seminars a lot so it's
lovely to be giving one myself
um
and so today i've decided uh to talk
about design spaces for visualization um
and how to develop them and this is
going to be a fairly methods oriented
talk because i figured that a stanford
ats seminar audience would be interested
in the sort of methodological
underpinnings um particularly those that
you know go beyond just visualization
and are more broadly applicable to hdi
although i'm certainly going to be
focused on visualization um in what i
say here
so
this term
design spaces
well this has been a continuing theme in
the visualization literature there was
an early paper uh from mckinley and card
in 1997 called the structure of the
information visualization design space
that might have actually been the first
time i personally had run across that
term used in this context
um and then it continued uh there was a
nice paper in 2009 for example from job
in elmquist exploring the design space
of composite visualizations if you have
say multiple views
um
a nice one on a design space for
visualization tasks i'll also be talking
some myself about uh design spaces for
visualization texts
uh this was by schultz at all in 2013.
uh really lovely paper just a few years
ago from madison elliott and other folks
from the vision science research
community on a design space of vision
science methods for visualization
research
so there's just quite a bit of these
papers that propose design spaces
so what exactly are they um
amusingly enough if you read a lot of
these papers they don't necessarily even
define the term they just use this term
and they often mean something in a rough
neighborhood all around a central point
although they're sort of differing
definitions my current one that i came
up with for this talk
um
gleaning from a few of uh of the
existing ones is you know imposing a
systematic structure on some set of
possibilities for a particular design
problem
and uh the idea is you're trying to
really capture the variables that are
central to design problem and the reason
is you're trying to support some kind of
reasoning about the set of choices that
you could pick in this design problem
now
what are people typically proposing
they're somehow delineating they're
they're giving a structure of that space
and a key part is that you have these
independent cross-cutting orthogonal
ways to divide things up uh sometimes
people call these axes or dimensions or
categories but the key ideas you've got
places in which you can make independent
choices that have been uh and so you
could you know enumerate the set of
possibilities in a way that helps you
think
now
people call these many things i picked
the word design spaces for this talk um
but people often call these taxonomies
sometimes they call them typologies and
they quibble about the difference
between those two they might call them
classifications uh more general terms
like frameworks even a super general
term like model
um
so you know in my own work i've called
these everything from design spaces to
taxonomies to typologies to frameworks
actually to classifications i've called
them all these things so
as i talk through some different papers
we've done in the past i might actually
switch between using these words that
i'm basically all using
um
so
i i particularly like there was one from
david and elmquist which is a longer one
a space within which to express design
patterns that's another
uh sort of useful way to think about
that
now what are they for
so
back in the cardinal mckinley paper um
their argument was that the reason they
wanted to describe and analyze portions
of the design space was to understand
the differences between designs and to
suggest new so there was this idea of
somehow think about how are things
different from each other how can you
use this in a creative way
now in the elliott paper um i like their
definition design spaces provide an
actionable structure for systematically
reasoning about solutions so somehow
there's this idea that it helps you do
something
and then there's an interesting paper
from pal ralph um that was actually
published in the transactions on
software engineering uh which has a lot
of very applicable advice for the hci
and visualization communities uh that
talks about methods for
both taxonomies and process theories
where he argues that taxonomies increase
cognitive efficiency and they support
inferences and the way that they do that
is they help you to group together
similar instances to let you reason
about that entire class rather than
point by point reason about the
instances of things in that design space
and i find that a very useful framing
so how do you know
if a design space is helpful or good or
better for a particular purpose than a
previously published one or useful in
any way whatsoever how do you assess a
design space that's a methodological
question
um
i'm particularly fond of a framework
that michelle bonnie lafont talked about
and he had in mind assessing interfaces
rather than design spaces or taxonomies
but i've actually used it quite a bit
for taxonomies and i find it instructive
to think about first of all descriptive
power does it give you the precision to
distinguish what you care about within a
set of existing examples so can you use
it to describe existing work in a way
that helps you think does it you know
put things in the same category that
really should be there and does it let
you distinguish between when you need to
for the purpose of reasoning and
exposition
then there's evaluative power
so the ability to help you from a set of
alternatives you're thinking about can
help you decide which one might be
better for a particular purpose
and then there's generative power does
it help you create something new so can
you define exist can you describe
existing can you evaluate possible and
can you generate new those are three
interesting ways to think about the
utility um and suitability of a design
space
so how do we create them
well a really common way and actually a
theme that runs through all of the ones
i'm going to talk about myself today is
this idea that it would happen through
an open coding process of source
material
and um in case that's not clear when i
say coding i don't mean programming
i mean this qualitative analysis method
where you're coming up with a set of
tags uh to describe um instances and
then you can use those to actually
create this categorization it's
typically a very iterative process a lot
of refinement uh sometimes it's called
just thematic analysis a particular
framework for doing that's called
grounded theory but i'm sort of going to
think about all these although they have
some you know
relatively subtle methodological
differences these are all ways that i'm
just going to talk about is open coding
some kind of source material
um
and we'll talk about different kinds of
source material and what that leads to
of course you could go off and read
research papers uh so in a literature
review then you're typically going to
say well there's a bunch of theories out
there maybe i'm going to synthesize a
new one and you often want to compare a
new design space to previous ones or
contextualize how yours
fits in to the previous work in that
area
and then there's a method of personal
reflection which is you just sit down
and think um
and of course any kind of an iterative
open coding process does have a certain
amount of you sitting down and thinking
um but uh having a design space that
includes thinking broadly means you
don't just have to be constrained by the
source material you're coding um it
really is something where you can think
quite a bit about for the purposes that
you're trying to create your design
space what would be a useful way to
structure things again to help you think
so i'm often going to call that
reflective synthesis to really um
highlight the idea that you're often
bringing many many things together in
some deep sense with everything you've
ever read or thought about
and that you're using as part of this
creation process so broader than just
open coding a specific corpus of source
material
now what's interesting of course is
you're not forced to do just one and
many real uh design space creation
processes have these sort of interesting
and complex combinations of those as
i'll get into
so i'm going to actually talk through
four major examples of creating a design
space
one is really focused on a data type of
um temporal data where the instances in
the design space are
visual encodings of timelines so you
know how do you actually make a visual
representation of a timeline
one is more domain focused in the domain
of genomic epidemiology um where the um
what we're thinking about is a design
space for how would you actually make
you know figures in research papers that
are helpful for researchers in this
field i'll often abbreviate that as gen
epi um
there's one in the domain of journalism
which is not focused on visual encoding
but focused on activities and tasks what
are people doing when they're wrangling
or cleaning data
and then finally there's a very domain
agnostic one about a design space for
abstract tasks so i'll be talking
through the similarities and differences
in developing these design spaces
so let's jump in let's now start talking
about timelines
so this is a paper um first off it was
matt bremer who at the time was a pt
student at ubc he's now at microsoft i'm
sorry at um tableau research um but this
was done um in part while he was at
microsoft research with uh bangtan lee
and natalie andres and benjamin bach was
also at msr at the time
so this paper is called timelines
revisited a design space and
considerations for expressive
storytelling and what we were thinking
about was what are some ways of creating
timelines specifically for presentation
so
there's often
a split between exploratory and
expository
or exploration and presentation in
visualization and so we're specifically
thinking of the context of presentation
so narrative intent something that's
interesting there
and we end up ended up proposing a
design space with three axes there was
this representation one about you know
how are things actually looking are they
linear do they wrap around radially is
it a two-dimensional matrix like a grid
or a spiral or just any sort of um
positional layout at all and then ideas
of scale if there's some idea of um you
know is do you know that you've got a
timeline that's purely chronological
um are you just interested in relative
um
differences between do you log scale it
is it just simply an order do you have
some idea of durations in between not
just points in time
and then finally for the layout is it
just one thing have you faceted into you
think of this as multiple views or
multiple timelines do they wrap around
or do you have a combination of those
so
if you think about this right there's
five and five and four so sort of
theoretically there could be up to a
hundred possibilities if we just
enumerate them all
um and we went through and thought for
these various combinations uh what we
wanted to do is think about you know how
are people actually using this what's
the narrative point um and when they're
when you're looking at that what is the
perceptual task that you're doing for
that particular visual coding right so
here's one where we've got a radio
layout and it's sequential and it's a
single unified one
and we could go on and say well what
about some other points in this design
space what are you trying to achieve
like compare sequence lengths between
these facets
or here's one where instead of a circle
we're looking at a spiral um so and it's
a slightly different perceptual task and
you can think about information density
um you know here's one where we've got a
grid so we went through and we did this
characterization
of both the narrative point and the
perceptual task that was at play in
these visual encodings
um
and an interesting outcome is
they're not all good and in particular
we propose of the hundred possibilities
we characterize 20 of them as what we
called viable combinations and by viable
we meant uh we had criteria of you know
purposeful you could actually use it for
a particular narrative purpose
interpretable in the sense that the
person viewing it could uh decode what
you were trying to encode
and then also generalizable it's not
tied to a very specific specific thing
but it's a general way that you can
encode uh this kind of temporal data
so we
proposed that these 20 were really the
viable ones out of the 100 possibilities
that the design space could afford
so a key question how did we do this
um
so the process we used to create this
model
was a sort of two-phase creation and
then analyzing so in order to create
that design space what we did is we
actually assembled a fairly extensive
corpus of source materials which was
actual you know visually encoded
timelines and we did this from say you
know infographics um you know
visualization technique papers uh tools
that allowed people to create timelines
so a really broad set of timelines um
and what we wanted to do was get
something that was as uh as broad
coverage as possible of the ways that
people would visually encode this
temporal data and then we did an open
coding process where we would look at
all these we would try to create groups
think about what a good exemplar was and
then think by actually sketching
alternatives with pen and paper you know
what are some other ways that this data
could have been represented that would
make sense
um and
of course a lot of iteration and the
result was that three axis design space
that i've shown you and then there was
this second phase where given that
design space we then went in and
analyzed and thought
of the combinatorics which ones do we
think are reasonable because a very
interesting hint was in that entire
corpus only 24 of those combinations
even appeared
um and we actually made a judgment call
about which ones we thought were a
appropriate and suitable use of
visualization um and there was 20 of
those that we actually thought were
wise choices for encoding
so let's go back to that lens for
assessing and think about okay how did
we argue that this design space was
useful um
and uh
so for descriptive power what we did is
we actually stole an idea out of machine
learning of gathering a second test set
so we thought of the corpus we used to
create the design space as the training
set although we didn't actually use
machine learning but we took this idea
and we
gathered a new set of timelines we had
not looked at when we created the design
space and then we checked whether all of
them were actually um covered in useful
ways in our
design space axes and in fact they were
all describable the whole set of
originals and the whole set of
additional test set ones all of them
could be described in this design space
and of that sort of aligning with our
take about what was viable we thought
that 253 of those were matching that set
that we thought were wise choices out of
the 100 uh theoretical combinatorial
possibilities
now in terms of generative power how did
we actually show that well we took those
20 viable designs and we instantiated a
uh authoring software um
what we call sandbox software just to
let people play with things and so we
implemented that and particularly having
animated transitions between each of
them so that if you were trying to do
something like create a you know
storytelling video uh you could and so
we then tried to find a representative
set of datasets that covered a lot of
the possibilities and actually used the
toolbox to create a bunch of these uh
timeline designs and we actually with
the paper had seven full videos going
through a timeline and telling stories
with it using this authoring software
that was built around this design space
uh and so that was how we tried to show
its generative power is that we could
actually build something to let people
use it um
and there's a nice adoption story um
this was both uh open sourced and it's
uh still up and running if you want to
play with it at timelinestorytaylor.com
and that's a free browser version and it
was also integrated into the microsoft
product power bi
as an add-on so that was a nice way of
getting stuff from research
directly into people's hands
okay
so
that was a little story about timelines
and that's data type now now let me tell
you a story about a domain about genomic
epidemiology jen abbey for short
because that's a lot of syllables
um
and this was work done in collaboration
with uh anakrasen who at the time was a
phd student at uh ubc um she's now at
tableau research and jen gardy uh who's
uh at the time was ubc professor she's
now at the gates foundation uh working
on malaria um and at the time both of
them actually uh were part-time
affiliated with the bc center for
disease control
um so they had a deep domain knowledge
in uh
the catholic immunology in particular
and so this gevit project was actually
both proposing a method and presenting a
typology created with that method
so let's take a look at that
so we proposed was a particular method
for creating typologies that was really
a mixed methods approach where we're
mixing qualitative and quantitative
approaches
in a very deliberate way
and so it was a sort of multi-phased
process that was built around the idea
that you'd have some big corpus of
research papers
and you could do an automatic literature
analysis phase
and then
based on the results of that you could
do visualization analysis that makes a
qualitative first phase followed by a
quantitative phase so let me talk you
through that
um this particular typology we developed
which we called gevit for genomic
epidemiology visualization typology um
in the first phase the analysis phase we
would actually go in and create clusters
so we would use nlp techniques to create
topic clusters and then we would use
those for stratified sampling to make
sure that we actually had coverage
across all of these clusters um
and so we used a random stratified
sampling approach for
taking for actually being able to sample
articles
and then extract figures from those
sample articles and then go in and do
open coding on what are they doing in
those figures
um
so
and i'll talk you through what the
actual three axes were give it in just a
sec
so what we called this was a not just a
design space but a domain prevalence
design space
so you know the big picture is that the
literature analysis could be used to
address this question of why are they
researching it what are you know the
clusters the topics that these papers
are about
and then the visual adjacent analysis
could first say how are they visualizing
and then for each of these how many
examples are there
so in particular
when we had this idea that you could say
well
in infectious disease genomic
epidemiology research articles we could
use text mining to find both the topics
that just came out of pure text mining
and also any uh concepts that domain
experts thought would be interesting to
make sure to be able to sample for
and then we could do that random
stratified sampling
take the output of that
try to describe what the elements are
and then quantify and that because we're
actually trying to be very careful and
systematic about coverage doing that
kind of account would be a reasonable
thing to do even though often in a
purely qualitative
analysis process we wouldn't normally
try to argue that counts are meaningful
in this one because of the care taken to
do that stratified sampling we do think
that in fact it's a reasonable thing to
do
so just to sort of click by the numbers
i'm not going to walk through all these
numbers but i want to point out why do
we have to be systematic it's because
when you start out and you do a
literature search on pubmed you get 18
000 articles and you're not going to you
know open code all of those so after we
did the clustering and removed articles
that didn't fit into clusters and then
we removed the articles without the
human pathogens and then removed sort of
you know very small topics we ended up
with a total of 18 of these topic
clusters that turned out to map very
clearly into particular pathogens that
cause diseases and then other a priori
concepts like surveillance or
all kinds of things like that that the
domain experts decided were useful so
they had these two sort of
cross-cutting ways to have um clusters
to sample and what they ended up doing
uh at the end of that sampling process
that i'm not going to go into in exact
detail here with a couple hundred
papers and those are something where you
can extract all the figures so that was
800 figures which is a lot but nowhere
near the you know tens of thousands that
we would have had
so what was the design space actually
going to look like we ended up saying
that one interesting thing was what
chart types are they using uh so common
charts and you know relational charts
like nodes and graphs temporal charts
spatial charts a lot of trees
phylogenetic and otherwise a lot of very
specific charts used in genomics um and
a collection of others and so one of the
one of the um axes of this design space
was well what chart type are they using
but then another axis was and how are
they combining it
are they doing any sort of spatial
alignment either horizontally or
vertically
or are they showing relationships
between these multiple charts with
something like matching color coding or
matching shape coding um are they using
the visualization technique of small
multiples to have the same visual
encoding across a bunch of disjoint data
sets
or did they just slam two figures side
by side as subfigures maybe just because
they had space constraints in their
article and even though they're next to
each other they don't actually have any
explicit alignment at all it's just sort
of more of a grab bag and since we were
doing this idea of uh stratified
sampling then we were able to actually
come up with counts of noting uh numbers
that we thought would be representative
of what people were doing
and finally the third axis is the idea
that they didn't just take something
that they might have automatically
generated they often added things on to
that uh sometimes with tools but often
manually
so
and what's interesting from a
visualization person's point of view is
it's very common to talk about point in
line area as types of marks that can
convey information which you can then
visually encode with channels like size
and shape and color but they did this
with text too they did a remarkable
amount of using fonts and colors and
even font face to try to express
categorizations um and uh so that was a
very uh somewhat surprising from a sort
of visualization dogma point of view of
just how much they were trying to use
the text properties itself to encode
additional information
so just to give make this a bit more
concrete uh here's an example of a
figure from a published article
and from the literature analysis we knew
that it was a particular pathogen in
this case enterococcus
and then from the
chart point of view we can say well
there was a tree and there was a heat
map and one of these sort of
one-dimensional heat maps we call
category stripe
in between and they were spatially
aligned where it meant something that
they had shared horizontal position
and then there were a bunch of these
other marks they actually added branches
between two different trees to show uh
where those species were the same
they um actually used color coding to
try to show these groupings within the
tree they added some of these annotation
marks
so let's think about what the this the
assessment of this one was um from a
descriptive power point of view it
really did provide a common language
which really hadn't been there before it
wasn't clear what kinds of
visualizations people were using in this
domain
and we were able to notice that aha
because we saw what they actually did
not just what the tool supported that
there was a huge amount of stuff they
were doing that was not supported by any
current tools once we saw the breadth of
what people were doing
in terms of evaluative power we could
see there are some shortfalls um you
know from a visualization point of view
perhaps over using you know text as a
way to convey uh information
perceptually
and in terms of generative power in some
follow-up work we did do the idea of
trying to actually build it to try to
take that design space and instantiate
it in this case as a recommender system
so using this idea of domain prevalence
and design space accounts to build
something um that would automatically
recommend the visual encoding for
particular uh combination of data sets
uh people are curious that's hot off the
presses
just got accepted into tvcg and we'll
present that it is in the fall
and there's a link to that
all right
that was the second one what about a
third one how did you think about design
spaces in data wrangling
so this is joint work with steve kasich
who's currently still a phd student at
ubc and charles barrett uh who at the
moment is a postdoc with me here at ubc
so this is an actionable framework for
multi-table data wrangling from an
artifact study of computational
journalism so what do i mean by that
all right this idea of data wrangling
sometimes this is called data cleaning
or um data cleansing or any of these um
things of you take the data set you have
to do something before you can actually
do the kind of analysis you had in mind
now journalists do a lot of data
wrangling um it's a general idea in data
science but journalists in particular
especially with the advent of a lot of
visual data journalism are doing a lot
of data wrangling
and what's interesting about it is they
show their work
a lot of that wrangling in many contexts
is done behind the scenes in all kinds
of domains but the journalists actually
tell you what they did um they literally
call it the nerd box that's the internal
name for when you have that little
sidebar or snippet that says well here's
the methods we use here's the link to
how we did the analysis
and so they actually publish their code
they will publish data wrangling code in
repositories whether github or
observable or there's many many hundreds
of these out there because there's a
journalistic value of transparency
editorial transparency so that the
public can actually see how you came to
the conclusions you did or a colleague
could reproduce that um so there's this
culture of transparency which makes it a
really interesting target for wrangling
research because we can see what people
are actually doing
so what we did in this this is what
we're calling a technical observation
study following some terminology from
that paul ralph paper i mentioned at the
very beginning
um
where the artifact that we're coding
is journalist software scripts
so
um to really understand what are
journalists doing journalists who code
how are they data wrangling um we had a
process for trying to make sure we had
good coverage of all of these repos and
then we did open coding of the software
scripts that did the wrangling
we also ended up creating sketches of
how the data flowed between the
different tables um because it ended up
being so unexpectedly complex
so
this was these were not things we found
in the repos these were our
interpretation of what the code in the
repos were actually doing
and the result of that process um was
very detailed taxonomy of how data
wrangling is done in computational
journalism and then we had a second
phase where we wanted to say given these
very bottom-up taxonomies how does this
align with previous work in the area and
let's make sure that our tags for our
codes in our open code set are actually
harmonized with this previous uh work
and where are their differences where do
the journalists do something which
hasn't been talked about by generic data
wrangling uh papers
so then we adapted that taxonomy and
iterated and refined it even more until
that was finalized and then said but
those taxonomies they have great
descriptive power but they don't seem to
have much generative power can we come
up with something that would be more uh
helpful in letting us build a tool to
address some of the pain points
and so there was this reflective
synthesis process where we
re-characterized in a design space that
was much more suited for having
generative power
so i'm not going to go into a great
detail on here i'll just mention that we
looked at a total of well over a
thousand repos and using a set of
inclusion criteria and then narrowed
that down to a set of a couple hundred
that were suitable and then we sampled
from that multiple times keeping uh some
diversity criteria into account trying
to make sure we had a range of
journalists uh large newsrooms small
newsrooms
um and so we ended up open coding 50 of
those in great detail um to generate uh
the first level taxonomies and then went
into this alignment process
um and had a taxonomy with a total of
165 codes and then created this much
more concise framework and checked it
against the first set of taxonomies
so what are these um i'm not going to
walk you through every single detail of
them but at the high level there's
actions taken by journalists uh and
there's processes that was our
interpretation of what we thought they
were doing uh and we really wanted to
distinguish between those uh because one
was um interpretive and one was much
more descriptive
and this had a lot of power this was uh
quite detailed it went down five levels
to some very detailed descriptions a
total of 165 codes in that code set
across both
so that was great for description
but it wasn't really something that we
could use to build tools around and so
that's when we started thinking well
what what is interesting here what are
the points of divergence and the sheer
number of tables that journalists were
using was jaw dropping these are all
some of these uh diagrams trying to show
what was happening with data flow
between tables there's a lot of arrows
here
and uh so we found you know there were
some quite relatively simple ones but
also some very very complex ones and it
wasn't well supported by any kind of
interacting interactive wrangling tools
like you know something like uh trifacta
or tableau prep or that kind of thing
these weren't scaling to the sheer
number of tables and the ways that
people were chopping them up and shoving
them together
so
we thought well how could we think about
a framework that would let you build a
tool to support this kind of stuff much
more uh cleanly than anything we saw
before so we proposed a design space
with two axes
one is focused on the kind of thing
they're doing is it a table or a row
or a column
and one was focused on essentially what
kinds of operations are they doing in
terms of um the number of things in and
the number of things out
so creation is where you go from nothing
to something
deletion is where you go from one thing
to know things and then any kind of a
one-to-one transformation or any kind of
a separation from one thing into many
are combining many back down into one
and that actually gave us a really
concise and quite actionable design
space that we thought had suitable
generative power for thinking about this
and uh
so that was an example where we really
needed to go from one design space to
another where we thought differently
about descriptive versus generative
power so that we had something we
thought we could build a tool around
then we did want to make sure that this
new
space actually covered all the cases of
the actions taxonomy and in fact it did
spoiler alert
so
let me just go back to this one moment
um we haven't actually built this tool
yet
we do hope to in fact i'm actively
looking uh for um any sort of journalist
partners who'd be interested in working
with us
we've already talked to the folks uh
behind open refine and we really are
interested in building kind of a
multi-table wrangling framework um and
so i'm actively looking for
collaboration partners as we go from
this investigation to actually doing
tool building quite soon
okay so now for our last one let's think
a little bit about abstract
tasks so
this multi-level typology of abstract
visualization tasks was joint work with
matt bramer when he was still a phd
student
people have thought a lot about tasks in
visualization and the need to somehow in
a domain-independent way say what are
people doing um
and sometimes they call them tasks or
goals or intentions or objectives or
activities or interactions they use a
lot of different words that are all sort
of in the same general ballpark
a lot of these are quite low level right
like a retrieve of value or you know
find maximum value very very low level
operations and some of them are
incredibly high level like integrate
insight um
and what we argued was there was really
a gap between these that needed
addressing about how to go from you know
between low and high so a multi-level
taxonomy to help you along
and there have been some work in that
area but but not nearly as much
so
what we did was a process where we went
very deep very deep into the literature
and also very deep into reading and
thinking so we did a combination of open
coding of the literature where we read
dozens and dozens of papers grabbed all
of the words they used to describe any
of these tasks and then tried to come up
with something that was integrated
across all of them but suitable for a
visualization context so a lot of
reading and thinking rearranging trying
to group trying to simplify and
iterating
where what we were open coding was what
had been proposed both in actual
taxonomies and any other research papers
that address these questions of abstract
tasks
we did a lot of this there was a lot of
iteration you can see some physical
whiteboards all kinds of digital
whiteboards where we went through and
came up with many many possibilities
as we finally ended up with a quite
concise taxonomy of 27 terms that we
thought suitably covered
a big hunk of the visualization
task design space
in that final one we had three axes and
the two really well developed ones were
why and how and there was also a sort of
um stub what space of just thinking that
there'd be data as input and data as
output uh as possibilities in a sequence
of tasks
but we're really quite focused on the
why and the how
now
what we also did in this somewhat heroic
table um is this is a lookup table where
we mapped for every of our 27 terms we
said exactly where in the previous work
that term or or what we considered
synonyms were used so this was actually
across 30 previous taxonomies plus 20
more papers that went deep into these
questions of abstract tasks
so for example navigate you know a bunch
of the previous work just used the word
navigate but some used words like pan or
detail on demand or drill down or any of
a number of other words that we consider
to be in this category and so this was
direct references to all those papers
or compare right some previous
taxonomies actually used the word
compare others would use words like
discriminate or associate for example
so this was really to try to give a very
clear connection to
this rich rich vein of previous work
and
let people understand how what we were
proposing
connected in detail to all of that
previous work
now we didn't just do this sort of
bottom-up uh approach of um looking at
uh what other taxonomies had proposed we
also looked at a lot of theoretical
lenses which was more of a top-down
thing so one of the things we're
thinking of for example was don norman's
stages of action
heidi lam's extension of that to add
ideas of the gulf of goal formation uh
the literature on distributed cognition
and sense making from park and other
places play theory um some of my own
previous work on what i call the nested
model of visualization that really
distinguish between thinking about
things at a domain specific level
abstracting that in terms of both the
data and the task and then and visual
encoding and interaction techniques and
finally the level of algorithm design
and this was deliberately made to fit
into those middle two levels that
focusing on the why of
of tasks and the what of data and
connecting that into the how of visual
encoding and interaction techniques
so thinking about that in terms of these
again three ways to assess um
we found that we had something with a
lot of descriptive power it was possible
to analyze
a lot of existing interfaces in terms of
sequences of these tasks which really
helped us think about both the eventual
ends and also the means to that end when
you decomposed what was going on
in visualization systems
it also was really targeted at having
generative power of when you were in the
early stages of problem-driven work uh
that kind of work is often called design
studies in the visualization literature
where
when you're in the process of trying to
abstract from domain specific stuff to a
layer that's agnostic to what domain it
came from when you're doing that
requirements gathering that's really
where we wanted people to be able to
focus
um and then for evaluative power we did
explicitly see this as something that
would let you have a code set if you
were doing field studies or maybe a task
set if you're proposing what people
would do in a lab study and to be able
to connect that with this really
voluminous previous work um so to
possibly get better external validity
for any kind of a formal experiment
what's really gratifying is the
community has responded with adopting uh
this framework so there's been hundreds
of people who have used this for all
three of descriptive and generative and
evaluative purposes uh so that's been
really heartening to see
i myself continued on uh with this uh
that book manish mentioned was actually
really very much built on top of this
idea and i fleshed out even more this
question of how
um and in some sense the entire book is
like one huge design space uh with you
know how are we able to have visual
encoding and interaction
techniques or idioms and why are we
doing it in terms of task abstraction
and i also went much deeper into the
what as well
so this kind of thinking about design
spaces for visualization as a whole is
something i've been quite engaged in in
part because i tried to think about how
to describe it in a unified way in this
book
i'll mention for those who love
abstraction there was an interesting
follow-on paper um from just a few years
ago where we thought not just about
these mid-level tasks but trying to tie
those to higher level analysis goals
where again we constructed a design
space
and the source material was that we
extracted descriptions of analysis from
these problem-driven design study papers
uh because there's been quite a corpus
of those published um in the years
before that
but i'm not going to get into that today
because we have a limited time
so i've talked about a number of
different design spaces and let me think
about similarities and differences
so
we've had these four
timelines gen epi wrangling tasks
now in all of them there was some amount
of open coding of source material either
actual visual encodings of timelines or
figures from research papers or software
from repositories or tasks that were
extracted from research papers
now
there was also different strategies for
sampling in some we had to assemble the
corpus and that was part of the
intellectual contribution and then we
went through and used the entire corpus
in some we had this huge space for
example you know research papers in uh
genomic epidemiology where there's tens
of thousands and then we had a very
systematic approach of stratified random
sampling of these clusters so that we
could actually then do some
quantification because we were being
systematic um in others we had something
much more qualitative like in the
wrangling study uh we did have this idea
of having different criteria for
diversity of which of those repos we
would open code to try to make sure we
got reasonable coverage and hit
theoretical saturation
and then with the abstract tasks we
weren't trying to sample we were trying
to see everything we were trying to grab
it all and put it all together in one
unified way so pretty different sampling
strategies
there was reflective synthesis in three
out of the four but it happened at
different phases in some it was an early
phase thing where even from the
beginning we were doing a combination of
open coding and thinking about what we
thought would be something useful
whereas with the wrangling one we did
that late where we assembled an entire
taxonomy with the truly brought them up
process
and then thought about could we come up
with something different that would
actually give us generative power so it
was a late stage reflective synthesis
in terms of you know connecting with
previous research literature we
basically just mined that for some
source material for the timelines
project
we didn't explicitly do a viz research
search although we were certainly
informed by that as part of the genetic
project and then we very explicitly
tried to make sure we connected to that
research what i'll call a light mapping
pass with the wrangling project and a
really deep and thorough mapping path to
that previous work in the task project
so thinking about descriptive power um
we tried validation against a test set
for the timeline project we had this
really systematic method um that gave us
a lot of very comprehensive coverage for
the genepi project
we had this really high precision
descriptive power that allowed us to
find
where the other work that wasn't
specific to journalists diverged from
what that group did
and then we had this um quite widespread
adoption of the task taxonomy
showing that there was quite a bit of
descriptive power in that one
now for generative power for two of
these we built one we built in the paper
itself one we built in in implementation
in a follow-up paper uh the third we
plan to build um so this idea that you
could use a design space as the basis
for some sort of software implementation
um and then there was quite a bit of
usage of the abstract cast technology
when people were doing these sort of um
design focused visualization projects
after that was published
now what i think is interesting is
thinking about the descriptive versus
the generative power
so in one in the timelines we had
something where we used analysis to
characterize a subset uh to give us more
generative power and with gen epi we use
the exactly the same ones we didn't have
this distinction and it was a very
detailed fine-grained one
whereas with the wrangling paper we
didn't take a subset we actually
developed something completely new to
get generative power
and then with the abstract tasks again
it was the same but it was a very
concise one so we had generative power
in mind from the beginning as we thought
about those so these different um
approaches and we really focused much
more on evaluative power really only in
that last one
and that brings me to discussing the
assessment what i find is i always think
about generative and descriptive power
and i find sometimes it's less easy to
think about when could you distinguish
the power to evaluate alternatives from
the power to generate new or describe
existing and i find often in my own
thinking that's less obviously a third
category than the descriptive versus
generative
so i want to come back as a wrap up to
this thinking about well how do we
assess taxonomies and to sort of frame
this in the larger context of different
kinds of theories
so for example ben schneiderman who's
designing the ui book talks about
descriptive theories explanatory
theories you can imagine taxonomies
possibly fitting into that but
definitely this idea of a prescriptive
theory or predictive theory that's not
what a taxonomy or a design space is
trying to do
and i really like the way that paul
ralph talked about it in this really
intriguing paper that i'm going to
encourage folks in hci and viz to really
dive into it's quite recent
and um he talks about different kinds of
theories as theories for understanding
where you organize something into useful
categories that's exactly a taxonomy
versus process theories where you think
about how something happens uh ralph
argues these are often sort of augmented
taxonomies so it's useful to think about
them together
and he's really separating them from
theories of variance explanations of why
something happens where you've got some
sort of causality relationship these are
the kinds of things you can use for
prediction and that's not what
taxonomies and design spaces are
typically all about
and so since we're not doing that kind
of predictive thing this has
implications for how do we assess
taxonomies these are different criteria
than the bodily phone three ones um and
he goes through and discusses
essentially which criteria he thinks are
relevant for taxonomies like parsimony
transferability outside the corpus you
made it from ideas of theoretical
saturation to really make sure you've
extracted everything you can
sometimes questions like is it useful is
it original does it resonate or is it
perhaps not necessarily resonating by
being something um surprising and new
can you test it these are all
interesting but are not necessarily
required and then specifically argues
that questions like statistical
generalizability and things like
construct or internal or conclusion
validity those are the kinds of
questions you ask of predictive theories
like variance series but not for the
kind of stuff we're doing with design
spaces and taxonomies so i find this a
useful way to guide thinking and i
wonder if it's a field we could really
make these distinctions and think about
these criteria in addition to
descriptive and generative and
evaluative power
so that i'd like to wrap things up um if
people are interested these talk slides
are already posted publicly um the book
i mentioned um is something you could
certainly have a look at because it's
essentially one big giant design space
for all of visualization and then lots
of stuff on both my research group page
and my personal page of uh courses
papers videos software and many other
talks so thanks so much
all right
thank you tamara
that was great
and
um one of the downsides of virtual talks
is that you can't hear all the clapping
so uh we have plenty of time for
questions um and so we'll open up the
floor for those uh if you're an attendee
please
post your question to the to the
chat
and
will will help us get those
uh to
tomorrow um
so
while those are coming in
um
i had a question which is
okay that was a really great um
you know it's really great to see those
three different examples of how to build
this kind of taxonomy and design space
and
one of the things that i was wondering
is um
have you thought about tools that could
help you
build these kinds of taxonomies for
different design spaces
um
at least somewhat
so for example that
that
gevit project where we had this idea of
you need tools that lets you go inhale a
giant corpus of literature and help you
find these topics so you could do the
sampling um anna actually ended up just
instantiating that as an r package
called adjutant we have a separate paper
that's just introducing that and people
have ended up using that for this kind
of uh taxonomy creation where you want
to sample a really large literature so
we have at least um got one tool for
that i think there's so much more that
you could do um and i think particularly
i mean i know there's a lot of software
for sort of doing generic open coding
but in a lot of the ways that we did our
open coding i don't know that it would
have helped i think that if your source
material is like
audio files where you want to create
transcripts and then code them or video
files i think there's some software
support for that but where you're
thinking about you know the space of
timelines you know matt brainer did a
whole lot with pencil and paper um and
pen and paper so i i feel like the more
exotic your source material the more we
don't have good tools and one of the
things i emphasize in this talk was just
how broad your set of source material
could be it's not just you stick a video
camera down and you film somebody
right
um we have a question coming in
uh
do you want to read the question yeah
um this is a question
uh how would you explore the three
dimensions descriptive generative
evaluative powers starting from a
specific data type
um
so let me actually
go back here a moment all right
uh
the um
in the example where we said for a
specific data type like with temporal
data um
you know with the timeline project we
said you know we're not interested in
you know tabular data necessarily just
you know generic tables or loading
crafts we're very specifically
interested in data that had this
temporal component and so then when we
went through and thought about
the descriptive regenerative power it
was you know do you want to describe
things using that particular kind of
data type so if for example we had been
looking at network data where we had
node link um relationships then um a
bunch of the
questions like instead of just having um
you know things like is it radial versus
you know a grid rectilinear grid versus
linear we might have had questions like
you know with
network data are we showing it as actual
nodes connected by link marks between
them are we showing it as something like
an adjacency matrix that's a completely
different
visual technique for showing that so
the
kinds of things that we would do would
be dependent on how people would
typically say visually encode that kind
of a data type
um
and uh
so i'm not sure if that exactly answers
your question
um
we'll wait for i guess we don't have
like yeah multi-way operations also
somebody asked to put in the chat let me
um actually
uh copy that link
and
put that in the chat
and i think i can send that to everyone
[Music]
there's that
so maybe i'll ask another question as
we're
as we're here um so
you know the three domains you picked
were really really interesting and um
i was wondering if you could talk a
little bit about how you choose the
domains
to focus on what's do you have a process
there
how does that how does that work for you
um you mean like how we pick to do these
different projects like gen epi versus
journalism yeah
the whole project at all yeah no just
how yeah versus timelines versus tasks
yeah um
i mean you know the short answer is i
tend to be pretty opportunistic and you
know um anna came and was someone who
was an expert in genomic epidemiology
and wanted to do a phd and you know
going deeper into visualization for gen
epi so that's how we picked the domain
because that was her domain of expertise
and interest
um you know with timelines uh that was
something when matt bremer was at
microsoft research
uh on an internship during his phd it
was a bit of a continuation of some work
we had done with a project called
timeline curator which was an authoring
system for timeline so we'd we'd sort of
already started thinking about temporal
data and then he just went to town and
went deeper into that
with the data wrangling for journalists
steve kasich came to me as someone who
had a background in journalism and
decided visualization was great and
backfilled himself into a computer
science background just so we could
visualize stuff in a journalistic
context so we sort of he came to me with
that domain in mind already
and then it took a bunch of looking
around until we decided to focus on
wrangling in particular is a nice open
area so you know i feel like my answer
is
depending on who comes to me in terms of
collaborators or um you know the
possibility of people with data sets and
so on i tend to just say
let's see if there's anything here that
could make a cool research project so
that's not a very principled answer but
that's the reality well that's fine are
there areas that you think would be ripe
for
you know you or others to to look at
um
guess i tend to think that
i mean i personally and maybe this is me
just sort of rationalizing what i like
doing but i think there's great value in
going back and forth between specific in
general you know it's not a coincidence
that i had three more specific things
and then the super general one and i
feel like
you you know you basically like there's
sort of different lenses right and one
lens is a data type lens and one lens is
an application domain lens and one lens
is a sort of technique lens like you
know what are you trying to do and what
are techniques for doing that
and and all of those have value and so
you know i think for any one of those i
could then answer the question like say
you know well what's understudy you know
you and i were just talking about text
as something where you know in my sort
of world view there's three major data
types which is tables and networks and
spatial data and what you do with text
is you sort of do a lot of
transformations but
in order to turn into one of those and
so
um you know with with domains i mean
there's a lot of domains that have
a lot of data
um sometimes even a lot of funding um
and
have a history of making poor human
beings do things that as a computer
scientist you're like oh my god that's
what computers are for stop making a
grad student do that kind of
stuff and i feel like biology and
genomics is just one where i'm like
computer science could make your life
better um
even while understanding that what
they're doing in that domain is big and
complicated and you can't just hit the
button and say analyze you're going to
need humans in that loop for a very long
time coming so i think domains with
intrinsic complexity where you're not
just going to automate your way out of
their analysis problems anytime soon are
really great domains to be thinking
about
and so
it's kind of a long-winded answer to say
at some level all of it but there's
definitely particular sort of understudy
data types or techniques or domains that
are just rich rich problem sources you
know i like journalism because you know
at the end of the day it matters in the
world they often you know it spans the
spectrum from you know talking to humans
to analyzing big you know leaked data
dumps or freedom of information act
requests where you might have a lot of
document analysis to do but you're
really trying to go back and forth
um so i like that as a particular data
science domain but there's many many
many others i basically i don't think
there's a domain i wouldn't like if i
found
you know the right collaborator there's
just so such a richness of domains
yeah it's one of the nice things about
visualization generally um yeah
tomorrow unfortunately we are out of
time so thank you so much for the talk
and um
thank you for
visiting us here at stanford
yeah well i'm sorry that i couldn't make
it there in person but i appreciate the
opportunity to talk to all of you by
zoom and thank you so much
all right thank you everyone